[Music]
tonight four amazing restaurants will
battle it out replace the file of my
best restaurant competition and it's the
mother of all battles with the winners
of the British Indian North African and
French heats facing sudden-death
elimination I'm gonna be testing them to
breaking point the table is just
commenting on cereal complainers the two
surviving restaurants will go on to face
an onslaught of tough challenges this
space now becomes your restaurants who
will go through to the final last week
Bristol's Connery Wizards Casimir
triumphs in the first semi-final well
done you can smoke up now Paul
restaurants will compete in the second
semi-final for a chance to take on
Casimir in the grand final
competing for that place the best of
British Sheffield's the milestone Indian
winners from Bradford brush art my Beth
North African a zoo from London and
finally winner of the fringe heat wind
Egan fields from Lincolnshire first I
want to know if they've corrected the
problems that I identified early in the
competition you need to look make a
service to help me find out I sent in a
team of secret diners but there's a big
surprise in store for these restaurants
I'm going to throw two of them out right
now it's sudden-death elimination which
two restaurants will survive first to
face possible elimination
our French winners wynjym fields head
chef and owner Colin is aiming for the
ultimate fine dining experience
he's created a luxurious dining room and
serves exquisite food but I thought
Colin was trying too hard
overloading his diners with too many
appetizers and too many waiters 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 move anymore let's go
you guys just check there's no one in
here
no with their place in the final at
stake I've since sent in another secret
diner Rob Allison an expert foodie with
a critical eye and I've sent all my
semi-finalists their own copy of the
footage so that they know what I'm
judging them on this is our second
appetizer amuse-bouche sometimes these
little touches get too much and I've
ordered my meal I want my long scenes
I've told Colin endless times less is
more and here we go again thank you
perfect thank you this looks delicious
but it's not mine
[Music]
really perfectly cooked long steam I
mean the mix of only the start I mean
disaster I mean it happens probably 1%
of the time and it's thin
yeah it's just not good enough next to
face undercover scrutiny our indian
winners prasad from Bradford mum calcium
and daughter Norma now produce some of
the best food I've ever eaten and it's
all vegetarian
that's delicious one mouthful of that I
feel like I'm back in Mumbai now I can't
leave that to waste I gotta eat some
more that I'm sorry Jesus
son Bobby runs front-of-house with charm
and wolves
Cheryl farmer is a food expert with 20
years experience I'm expecting her to
love this place as much as I did but
when she went in undercover Bobby wasn't
anywhere to be seen
instead another member of staff was
running front of house be nice to be
offered a drink at the fire isn't it
nobody asking the secret diner for
drinks and they're just left alone I
mean this doesn't even look like the
same restaurant soundproofing on the
kitchen it's nice to a kind of chats are
in the background but you only have
people scraping the pandas out you can
hear this kitchen porter by the sound of
things beating the hell out of these
pans cleaning this looks like completely
different restaurants other dishes were
really nicely spiced my secret diners
love the food thank God
because they're not enjoying the service
goons gonna absolutely crucify me it's
about getting it right every time
the contrast from that footage in
comparison to why I received last time
it's night and day next to face my video
evidence is a zoo from London in the
North African heat
head chef Chris produce some wonderful
authentic Algerian food delicious merci
but my coach trip exposed some
weaknesses front-of-house that's done
twice I've sent an undercover critic
Simon Davis to see if Chris assigned out
his front-of-house problems and is still
sending out perfectly cooked food that's
the chicken man damn disappointing
I've chicken slightly overcooked from
dry simple charming and delicious but
they have to be consistent finally it's
the milestone from Sheffield run by four
ambitious young men
this restaurant is reinventing classic
British food but they made errors when
my last secret diner paid a visit
would you either no so why should I use
it to progress in this competition I
need to know the milestone team are
learning from their mistakes
cumin seeds in they starts with our
little freebie homemade who's with cumin
a flatbread
next up its place for this serve with a
lemon pith puree what it's a nice hearty
place is a delicate fish and it needs
help acidic certainly but not maybe
lemon pit slightly bitter
my one problem with milestone is their
lack of experience can they get better
I'm a month seven all four rations are
waiting with bated breath for a phone
call from me they know that two of them
are about to leave the competition
so chance
[Music]
it's all on this phone call Baylor
[Music]
as a restaurant I'm help you hi
oh hey Monsieur hi Simon hello good and
how are you I'm good I'm a little bit
stressed but well I have to eliminate
two tables Zhu is not going any further
in the competition that's no problem
thank you very much sorry no worries
okay thank you
merci beaucoup Monsieur Java answer it
stops here it's really disappointing for
not winning I am like gutted I wanted to
win this competition with my soul I'm
taking a break
[Music]
not gonna get easier Simon I am really
fine but you guys gonna have to keep on
working
[Music]
congratulations cheers yeah stop just at
our tone well done take care thank you
[Music]
common points are words how much it
means to me personally it's the biggest
thing I've ever done for my career
it's the second semi-final of my
nationwide restaurant competition as you
are out and British Heat win as the
milestone have survived my sudden-death
elimination they will now compete for
place in the final against either my
best Indian Prasad
or my best French restaurant Winningham
fields
how's that Kullen yes it is hi Bob is
Gordon hi Gordon Bobby yeah yeah from
this competition position like I got
[Music]
support of the dining room
[Music]
cash in on a daily basis yeah
Windham feel
[Music]
is leaving the competition
okay what okay bye-bye
I'm getting because I know we are you
know so much better than that so that's
consistency for you know you need to be
you know bang on every time all the time
[Music]
because you go through to the next page
[Music]
Bobby I will never ever let you down
again congratulations thank you thank
you so much thank you they need to focus
now and he's been given a lifeline and
the restaurants across the board is too
good to leave his competition to
fantastic restaurants remained both
desperate for a place in the final now
I've got a big shot for them I'm about
to pay a surprise visit to my two
remaining semi-finalists to help me
decide on who should go through to the
final I've enlisted two trusted
lieutenants for a second opinion on the
strengths and the weaknesses of his
amazing restaurants Michigan starred
chef Angela Hartnett needs no
introduction an undercover diner Simon
Davis a top restaurant critic and a
confirmed carnivore
it's time to surprise Prashant in
Bradford the rest of the doctors but
they have the biggest heart I know
they'll fight tooth and nail for a place
in the final and after letting my secret
diner down they'll need to find I like
the rebleeding these guys and say is I
mean nothing less than perfect
today prasad will need to pull out all
the stops to impress us but they have
absolutely no idea that we're about to
walk through the door when I cough and I
get panicky you know I just found my
first bug bad that bloody door a lot of
steps in super sharp thank you I'm very
very privileged to see you actually any
drinks for you my girl s is not fixing
I'll have a fflewddur okay all right
thank you thank you nice warm reception
yeah I know Prasad will be trying to
impress me today but every customer
needs the same treatment so I've got
another trick up my sleeve
Angela's mum Giuliana is here too she's
also a fantastic chef and she'll be a
secret extra pair of eyes and ears
probably were up against at the time I
stayed on 90 minutes and so thank you so
much we're hungry and we want to try as
much of this food as possible so we're
gonna bombard the kitchen with orders
I'd like to go for the masala dosa para
para to God Pikachu E and then maybe
suppori as well then surely the special
shot corn roll as well please anything
else you'd recommend I'm sorry Jason
let's stay sir I had was in Delhi
yeah give me a masala dosa and do that
perfect you can complete with Delhi guys
listen yeah I don't want any mistake
this is a big order manal is focused on
my table but will she pay as much
attention to anglers mum in a great
restaurant every diner is a VIP
lumberjack now you don't need to panic
you don't need to delivers we're on fire
this is Prashant this is what we do okay
means very very focused
media shouting is fine as long as it
produces results I need 40 years I don't
need any now
[Music]
swagged antiques another hint you Simon
[Music]
the contented Sutherlands at our table
speaks volumes fantastic and I may have
our Duvall dish after dish is delivered
with charm Angela that Shih Tzu Chi
Thien chatter with no carry on that came
each one getting way above the mark
wasn't that amazing
it just looks a brand grand authentic
and smells amazing like a banquet
[Music]
and it's absolutely selection of option
amun-ra absolutely no this exceptional
vegetarian cuisine mom
Meena oh my god they're loving the food
who's missing meat not me
it's time to give Prasad a collective
appraisal so I was a bit nervous come
about today to be totally honest Anjali
I was a few I know for me phenomenal
food absolutely phenomenal blown away I
thought you're so good
masala dosa Oh as good as the one I had
in Delhi a yeah it's brilliant
yep sleeper Simon the stuff you do just
you know beggars belief that kofta with
the cauliflower is just a revelation
yeah and food today
flawless outstanding lovely warm service
but we've been watching everything I
mean every table and there's another
surprise because we have an
extraordinary lady here mrs. Hartman and
his mum what do you honestly think
moment in our fabulous food I love those
balls with potatoes and dog everything
is perfect and Bobby the service good
would you come back Oh today was about
redemption and you certainly redeemed
yourselves and this whole experience
will help me decide on who's going
through the final thank you for a
delicious delicious lunch you do
something without door please alarm
thank you thank you
you know three heavyweights in the food
industry turning up to annex laundrette
in the middle of Bradford's looking for
fault been demanding being difficult and
could we find fault no we're back on
track but back there but I think we're
gonna go win
my other semi finalist is the milestone
okay Sheffield how will they cope with
the three of us dropping in for a
surprise dinner Oh guys that don't give
up on anything they read their own Pig
made their own bread
they churn our own butter and they
really are pushing abounding down beyond
belief so I think we're breasts hold the
watercress on very last of it going
since I first met the young guns have
impressed me with a mixture of classic
thanked rated British dishes it's about
your chief or yoga chefs producing your
own but we also run a cooking school
and an outside catering company as well
as the restaurant and I can't help but
feel they're trying too hard
yes with so many fingers in so many pies
sometimes they've fallen short of
perfection how are you boys doing expect
to see us did you know sauna time I'm
with two very influential guests and
we're gonna be looking at everything
several for three there's a table it's
just coming in my cereal complainers
they go everywhere in this slate you
know my wall the Adrenaline's pumping
he's the main man Easley so whose person
infest I know that we focus on me and my
guess but how will they treat Angelus
sister Anne who's eating on the other
side of the dining room working Joey
it's not your average most Soylent sheet
giant radish snow yeah the push the boat
out yeah yeah big time I just hope it
tastes as good as it sounds hey that's a
nicer seasonal H yet Simon and sous-chef
James have made their mark by breaking
all the rules seven up local ingredients
with a quirky twist for our starters
we've ordered black pudding with bacon
pepper mackerel with horseradish snow
and it's a matter consomme with a flower
pot full of tapanade for soil and pea
shoes very hard to read the soup
navigate your way around things like
this ice were thrown at the shack we'll
get his head
it's just gimmick isn't it no I've got
to say how it tastes
what's up that is definitely how much
Tappan are can you put in a dish like
that I mean I know that's the soil but
bloody hell
Jay my soil blessing more and this is
all they need to know less is more
[Music]
they're keen as mustard I mean really
keen but far too ambitious but they're a
good
the minute you start trying to become
too clever Europe for intense scrutiny
not gonna like the effect it mean cause
next for our mains
we've got more conventional
[Music]
salmon wrapped in a herb crust
vegetarian cannelloni and bavette of
beef I mean they're attractive looking
dishes I mean I like the presentation I
actually think this is a really well
sourced me well cooked well handled if I
had any criticism it would be the red
wine jus because it's really sweet it's
almost the consistency of being right
being us socially very nice mushrooms
delicious like but they just need to
brave it back in finally it's time for
putting a tree up strawberry desserts
Bakewell tart so that's nice that looks
just and a great local cheese board see
that and that fits this thing here looks
like it's out at Paris Hilton's bathroom
it doesn't make sense
Whittier it looks delicious and it
tastes delish
Eric ice cream what else misters
plantation best thing I've eaten sorry
this one here yeah that's actually noise
time to call the team together for a
debrief if I just say that was delicious
really good unfortunate didn't start
like that if there's one strong message
you're trying to bloody heart I've
tasted the greatness and tonight has
been a disappointment stick to what
you're good at doing yeah and for me to
think of any good restaurant is how
every other table has been looked after
and tonight there's no second surprise
we've actually got Angelus sister having
dinner was as well I didn't really like
the bread
I thought the bread was a bit heavy and
I liked the tomato thing I have to say I
love all that and what was your starter
James I had the black pudding
it was quite sticky and quite quite
heavy so don't worry about trying to be
too different when you're good at what
you do get back to what you're good at
doing and stick to that
[Music]
we feel like I've been told off by my
dad
yeah I say well it's constructive so we
have to take our chin do what we can
with the main thing yeah I'm
disappointed because I came back to the
milestone for a magical experience
hoping they'd learnt but they just want
to be different tonight is a big
disappointment
two amazing contenders Prashad from
Bradford and the milestone from
Sheffield are fighting to win the second
semi-final of my restaurant competition
we want to serve every single customer
like we do at home
wait no no no later tonight one of them
will make it into the final and have the
chance to be crowned with my best
restaurant Rashad and milestone once
again I've survived my secret diners and
a flying visit which really turned both
the restaurants upside down they both
now face one more grueling test for a
place in the final a challenge that
they've never faced before
I've called Prasad and the milestone to
meet me in North London good morning
honey you're probably thinking what in
the hell are we doing here this early in
the morning standing in a pretty
unimpressive room yeah and look at it
bare bleak this space now becomes your
restaurants
and you're gonna transform these four
walls into the most amazing pop-up
restaurant only one restaurants go
through to the final
make sure you I'm given each of them one
floor of this empty building they've got
just 12 hours to create an exciting
vibrant pop-up restaurant that will open
its doors at 7:00 p.m. for one night
only what restaurants are what a hottest
ticket in the food world they spring up
in unexpected locations cause a big
storm and then disappear overnight
both restaurants will have a 2,000 pound
budget if we split between the chef's
and front of house you want to feel like
you're in a wedding you want to feel
like you're in a party you've got to
make and create that atmosphere the
challenges massive leave the restaurant
has done anything like this before it
will push them to the very limit of
their creativity and the ingenuity that
players from the inside players the
decisions they make now could cost them
a place in the final requires assembling
the chef's are heading to some of
London's best markets to choose their
ingredients for tonight's menu Simon and
James are looking for fantastic meat too
well their diners we're looking towards
a thick enough pork belly so on people
to enjoy with again good quality for
cheeks liver Vince the master prides
itself on serving amazing classic
British food that's all the fixtures it
up
after that disappointing fine visits
they'll need to prove to me that they
can deliver great food plate up the
plate the people are gonna see something
different we're gonna coconut yeah
easy the heart noise that would one
calcium Annelle our inner element in the
vegetable market for the perfect
vegetarian lesson you need perfect
vegetables and here's the place faint oh
my god tomorrow's one box over there
Prashant serve up some of the most
delicious and exciting food I've ever
tasted this challenge will show me if
they have the potential to develop their
restaurant and prime outside their
comfort zone 15 yes coming yeah it does
in us see what it will be not foreign
yeah okay good let's head back to base
while their front of health teams make
their final purchases let's get that
yeah have a look at sixty of those I see
that any glass yeah yeah that's the
exact idea we're looking for
this is Prasad's chance to create an
incredible interior a million miles away
from this simple bread for the cafe so
we're gonna get some of this one then I
don't you want 3.8 meters of the other
one can I get five meters of the red go
get rid of the red you can have three
and a half meters of each of these could
I have five meters of both of those and
I'm canceling the red
the chefs of just six hours to create
culinary magic in a very show of concern
these humble ingredients into something
truly spectacular on the plate to
compete Prasad will need to make the
vegetarian menu really sing when you
make the curry is hard to make it
because we're making so fresh they're
getting getting on with it and still we
are preparing so yes I am little bit
nervous
we don't want to panic when you do the
panic then you always do the mistake
these dishes include baked yam and
potatoes with spiced coconut and peanut
filling vegetable peeler rice and stuff
baby aubergines in half yeah you stuffed
them with the masala masala yeah nice I
want both restaurants to amazing design
my diners I don't want carbon copies of
Prasad all the milestones okay you're
loading the van there yeah we're opening
just under four hours from now you know
that yeah give me feel Prasad what are
you doing what's the what's the
objective objective is to keep a wedding
fair to give you a little bit of an a
taste of the Asia Wow
quite a complicated table not plan for
oh my goodness it gets the more
complicated as we go along
okay guys wrote me just under four hours
yeah
get going yes as soon as got in wanting
it dawned on me what was ahead of us
we've got it before we don't know that
they lights down the kitchen they're
doing to do their side we need to make
sure with your outside so it's a lot
better honestly with the amount of time
we've got fingers crossed we will
literally just be ready Bobby has been
bowled with his plans for the space I
hope he has time to put it off still not
gain any further forward with these
tables unless I know where push for time
yeah yeah but just one downstairs pop
your head downstairs very quickly
[Music]
all right looking fantastic
[Music]
okay they're looking in a pretty good
shape aren't they they are and this is
looking like a campsite biggest mistake
we've made is we didn't go for
ready-made table right now we're sort of
on a second table yeah getting put
together we're opening in just under
three hours from now and I you know
we've got a lot to do yeah yeah what are
they they're coloring Jesus where's he
go [ __ ] camp shop we where we're
trying to go with it with the look in
the feel of the tables and match
everything with the whites and the
blacks Jesus Wow he's [ __ ] not
impressive God Bobby's in a mess and it
looks dreadful and pretty crap
nothing Forks and dreadful tables like
they've been hanging around outside a
pub can't see the end in sight
so quite nervous just two hours two
hours is a long time
we didn't come all this way to lose
because we couldn't build tables
downstairs the milestone are much happy
with bare tables but they haven't paid
any attention to the rest of their space
the tables look great yeah the
restaurant looks [ __ ] there's no thought
process with the Tarleton yard for walls
I'm interested in a stunning restaurant
yeah yeah
that's what I would like to see yeah but
have you got any fabrics no cushions or
what no all 9 pieces of furniture to
liven up no this is it the idea of a pop
of restaurants yeah it's not just the
location boys has shown on this page
tell me and you wear your own pigs you
make your own bread and coming the
dining room it's like I know what you
guys are like when you use your
imagination so I give you the
flexibility to go and do something out
the box
[Music]
for shame
[ __ ] up it's a one-night-only 2,000
pound to create something exciting and
magic :
the wow factor milestone are going for
something simplistic that paid it's safe
but that may not get you into the final
there's no lack of ambition in the
kitchen however Simon and James are
servants Larry and skate scampi with
their silver mullet and braised oxtail
accompanied by English squash and wild
mushrooms oxtail
yep so you should be happy that scoops
in time yeah tastes delicious really
nice if they pull this food off it will
be amazing what's this one here season
they're funny that's delicious
that's delicious figs are taking shape
to tables are done time is on our hands
you got all the cutting on the table for
both courses
no we've unwrapped it yet do you care
Bobby you do I I'm worried [ __ ] cutlery
plain-jane dining room and I know you
can do better I'm really sorry
with very little time left before
Prashad open their doors Cal she goes
upstairs to the dining room
we have made so many errors you know but
we can't constantly focus on them we
can't change those errors right now yeah
yeah
I'm sorry will boom this is it it shit's
a boost
if it goes bad back to Sheffield we've
done the best we can but we're here to
win it
listen to me yeah every part of what we
do is with our heart
we're a 22c restaurant working our butts
off if we're not good enough we're not
good enough we'll still give it our best
shot
we're opening it just under five minutes
from now and this is it everything
they've worked for all day depends on
the service and I've never have and even
that's been so dependent on an amazing
performance in the kitchen because both
restaurants have been let down by the
front of house and it's up to the
kitchen now to redeem themselves in a
big way and pull it back it's seven
o'clock and outside the pop-up
restaurants being run by my two
semi-finalists Q's of hungry diners wait
to be seated when those customers arrive
blow them away warm welcome a three-hour
service but prove to me tonight why you
deserve a place in the final good luck
to both restaurants
each restaurant can see 25 customers if
they can squeeze in a second sitting
they could serve as many as 50 see I
want them to really impress me and
ensure my diners have a thrilling
once-in-a-lifetime dining experience
straight away Bobby and his brother
Maher are charming their guests
the chef's have put together a theme
around a wedding or a little family
restaurant I really want you to be an
extended part of our family and enjoy a
meal but are their diners hearing the
Indian wedding bells talk to me about
the deck or I guess the wedding Bobby
and his team are quick on the draw and
start taking orders downstairs is a
different story
15 minutes into service and the
milestone still haven't taken any orders
Matt mark while you're guessing away get
some orders in here yeah they're not
here for the life-story they're here for
the experience come on it's driving me
[ __ ] same diamonds fall and not one
order into the kitchen
right jr. on 3 Optio 1 Pollock first
ticket in 25 minutes later meanwhile
Prashad sumptuous starters yam and
potato curry and marinated stuff leaf
parcels are flying off the pass I always
get hotter room temperature is that in
writing the right temperature
yes okay good it's quite a subtle flavor
yeah I've never seen food like this
coming from above it's raw taste your
food and stop rushing don't be so to me
who started to your guess we want to
serve every single customer like we do
at home okay okay darling
Olivia that's the start delicious
filling what what's the point of putting
in between two slices of raw yam 3 belly
one more
at last the milestone boys are getting
the food out yes yes I say
but there's mixed reviews the first two
tables food looks amazing
neat seasoning first two tables well
meet woody thankfully minal and Cousy
are starting to hit their stride their
Punjabi main courses of delicious at
mutter paneer peas with Indian curd
cheese an amazing spice stuffed
aubergine I'll go down a storm dish was
in the kitchen the milestone boys are in
full flow serving their manes of
pan-fried silver mullet and pork cooked
three ways
[Music]
very very starters went out and it was a
disaster
now that my courses are going out and it
seems to be a lot more settled and more
control outside more hungry diners are
waiting for the mill of their lives now
we should start from thinking I'll tell
you those tables yeah okay now there's a
queue outside for Prashad experience I
don't want the freezing cold nor do you
back upstairs tables rule 8 and keep
that energy in the dining room please
with just an hour of service left the
milestone are starting this second
sitting but upstairs Prashad seem to
have lost all urgency leaving hungry
diners waiting outside in the cold
at this rate there won't be enough time
before closing to take an extra sitting
come on come on go works all the same
time I'm sorry it's almost like it's a
it's like everyone's given up on come on
come on come on
unless the whole family pulls together
no one else will be eating it Prasad
tonight you know Kelsi could you
upstairs and help clear the tables
please yeah please we've got just under
one hour to go okay so can you go
upstairs and polish the table so we get
some water with some pot you guys I'm
telling to do it yeah because you need
help
there's listen listen to the tables you
have think to do so I'm asking them to
give you a hand and you'll get there I'm
gonna say no please go upstairs I'm
clearing tables
[Music]
you can get chippy with me yeah I'm
asking them your mum dig up stairs and
help you you get defensive
I do yeah because we don't like it to do
those jobs right fine don't clear the
table yourself we're clearing so she
can't promise the table no Sheik she
can't relay it no Wow yeah he cracked
under pressure cleaning tables away and
trying to set customers that are
standing outside in the cold it's
difficult to have that level of
arrogance and get it thrown in my face
like that you know that's that's it's
cool but stay calm and deal with it I'm
step to my public sector Gordon you know
he knows exactly what she would do what
shouldn't I'm really sad because I
respect that a man to stand up to him
like that
not clever Bobby has finally turned some
tables I mean Alan Cal she have fixed
the problems with their young starters
to the delight of Prasad's new guests a
young dish it's it's really spicy and
very tasty spice is not too hot it's
justice rice lovely
we started [ __ ] we can finish shrunk
wave them around three strong running
them around the face strong come on I
can't help but want to approach me and
say sorry but it's not the time No
come here boy I'm not here to fight with
you yeah I'm here to support big day
tough day everyone's under [ __ ]
pressure you've got 20 minutes left
pull it back 20 minutes left pull it
back let's camp here one second
ten seconds are in there yeah I love the
way both for shot and the milestone are
now doing everything they can to serve
their diners wonderful food wait no no
no no I'm both dining rooms are buzzing
as the final plays are being served best
course of evening I've had very
impressive
[Music]
five four three two one and stop turn
everything off please
yeah 10:00 p.m. and service is over it's
been a long tough day for both
restaurants I hope we won this can't
guarantee it there's no guarantees in
this for something which we've thought
we've lost before and with one so we
don't know
I know we need perform to the level that
we would normally a lot of people didn't
some people didn't like the food come
here come on
[Music]
really really protect my ladies we did
everything the first week I know I know
Prasad and the milestone have embraced
this huge challenge and have a lot of
satisfied customers but both restaurants
had problems in their kitchens and front
of house now I have to decide who
deserves a place in the final
[Music]
this has to be the toughest challenge
both restaurants have ever faced quite
frankly on both restaurants I was
disappointed because I knew that the
personalities didn't shine tonight you
undersold yourselves Bashar I didn't see
Bobby the face of Rashard tonight
let's be honest master and I felt that
you spent far too long getting those
first three or four tables in I'm
standing outside knocking get the orders
in get these guys out the traps
and on the back of your performance and
your performance let me tell you it is
so difficult to gauge an outright winner
- phenomenal restaurants were put on the
spot today
[Music]
the restaurant going through to the
final
[Music]
is
yeah
congratulations thank you thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
gotcha trailer any good [ __ ]
but under the day we did as best still
proud of what we did really proud of
James the boys and the restaurant chin
up get some chaos yeah welcome
yes good job you're in the final and
good luck
[Music]
what a final Prasad vs kisame a small 20
seater vegetarian Indian restaurant from
Bradford up against young guns a
Michelin star boys tip for the top
[ __ ] game on